Well,
the Joe Rogan experience,
well,
it's also that they're doing it publicly,
so they're doing it most,
I mean,
if you're,
you either reading comments or you're reading articles and if you're reading
articles,
they're just looking for something to be upset about that watch you.
And they'll say,
okay,
is this a viable target?
Yes,
we got confirmation what he said about changing diapers or his wife being a
better parent is a viable target.
Let's go after him.
And then they just formulate some bullshit argument about who you really are
based on what might've been a throw away or a concession to your wife or even
just a compliment to your wife or being self deprecating to yourself.
Yeah,
but it doesn't,
people don't,
they're not looking at things rationally.
They're just looking at targets.
It's particularly people that write articles.
You know,
what's the best article?
It's got gotta be negative.
Like one of the things that came out of all this a Facebook algorithm stuff is
you find out that Facebook realize somewhere early on that the way to encourage
engagement is to get people upset.
They get way more engaged and they go back and forth and inter interact with
these posts way more if they're upset than they do.
If they agree with it.
If they agree with it,
they might give it a like or a thumbs up and say,
hey,
that's great and that's it.
That's where it ends.
But if you know someone's talking about,
you know,
we shouldn't build the wall,
we should let everyone in.
And you put that on some fucking Trump guys page.
They
ah,
it's crazy.
I mean you will get thousands and thousands,
thousands
of interactions.
And so Facebook realized that the way to keep people,
and you know,
they could claim that,
that it's an algorithm and the algorithm just supports whatever the people are
really interested in.
But what they're interested in this conflict
that demonstrates my earlier point,
which I made up on the spot.
Yeah.
Ai is not a neutral thing is resourced from human perspectives.
And cause that is a type of AI not as complex as right now what we're going to
experience,
and I can't even imagine,
but what I'm saying is,
is it still die?
What I want to say.
Resourced from a human from a human perspective.
And yes,
of course we are evolved to respond more strongly to negativity than positivity
for loads of reasons.
And I think that's where we can stitch back to what we were saying about taking
personal responsibility for who you are.
Like that.
None of us after sit on social media guy fuck you.
Fuck you you but none of us have to do that.
We can try and resolve though.
I respect that some people don't have any other outlets.
They don't have the privileges I have of being out go to support groups where
people openly talk about this is the ways that I felt inferior today.
This is the ways that I'm trying to become a better man and a better father and
a back coworker.
You know,
like a lot of people aren't afforded those environments and probably the best
shot they got is having a go out with someone online.
And those people,
you know in a way deserve love and sympathy.
But until we on some level recognize that we can all are our own behaviors,
we can all are our own consciousness.
All right.
I don't see how there's going to be,
well at least then we can create a terrain upon which a better,
better systems can start to flourish.
Do you read comments?
No,
I actually like,
I'm too sensitive.
I can just about manage to listen to people's replies to like conversation like,
you know,
like sort of like,
yeah,
I don't go on to like,
I have a,
like I've work with someone who does my social media and like she,
she gives me stuff like here I'll respond to these things,
puts them out,
put on that because I don't,
uh,
I don't want to engage with that.
I don't want to like walk up and down any street knocking on the door.
Guy,
do you like me?
Do you like me?
You like me?
I don't want to deal with people's responses and various conditions.
Well,
it's also much like the articles,
the way people get a response out of you or the way that people to get your
reaction is to say something really negative.
You know,
you look at some,
sometimes when people are not that savvy when it comes to social media.
One of the things that,
one of the things that you'll notice is they'll interact,
and I've been guilty of this in the past before I sort of realized what I was
doing.
You would only respond to negative things like people were arguing with people.
Meanwhile people are saying nice things to you and you ignore them.
Yeah,
it's cause you don't,
you don't,
you at a certain level,
you don't have the physical time.
It doesn't exist to respond to everyone.
It's not possible.
If you get 13,000 comments on one of your posts,
how the fuck does anyone have time to respond to 13,000 people?
You can't.
And then you have email and you have Twitter and Facebook and Instagram and
just,
there's no way.
There's not enough time in this world.
So you would potentially would have responded to things that cause the more
visceral,
I saw someone saying something that was untrue.
I'm like,
fuck you,
that's untrue.
But then I realize like,
what are you,
why are you doing?
Like this is a new thing for people.
There's never been a time where people have had this instantaneous interaction
with people unfiltered on moderated globally.
Yeah.
It's very strange to,
to be able to do that and to be able to go back and forth and just,
just to be able to give your comments on things,
to be able to talk about things.
And it's very addictive to people.
Yeah,
that's right.
And that's why I'm very
cautious with it.
I have to sort of set my life out.
Like I'm essentially a monk
in a marriage that's basically our ugly.
Get up,
meditate,
do yoga,
do exercises,
do things that are positive for you.
Watch the way that you're thinking.